the FDA tells CBS this morning it is
looking at California as a potential
source of tainted romaine lettuce the
agency is warning people to throw out
all romaine because of fears it may
carry a potentially deadly strain of
e.coli Americans eat about thirty
million servings of romaine lettuce
every day and a Warner shows us why
tracking down the source of the
contaminated product produce is so hard
so easily forget about serving this
tossed salad on the Thanksgiving table
all these leafy greens at Alameda
natural grocery in California are going
straight to the garbage cases of romaine
packages of romaine probably over 200
pounds of lettuce we've thrown away
today
health officials say romaine lettuce
should be removed from all supermarket
shelves and restaurant menus until they
can determine the source of a new ecoli
outbreak a potentially deadly strain of
the bacteria has sickened 32 people in
11 states since October nearly a third
of the cases nine are in Los Angeles
County Scott Horsfall the CEO of the
California leafy greens marketing
agreement says most of the romaine on
the market when the outbreak began was
grown in his state given the heart of a
cycle at that time I think there's
there's a there's a good possibility
that it came from California yes but he
also says finding the exact farm will be
difficult because it takes about two to
three weeks for investigators to confirm
an e.coli outbreak is underway so by the
time they're actually doing trace back
there is no packaging left there's no
product left an important clue for
investigators is the bacteria's DNA it's
very similar to the e.coli strain that
caused a still unsolved outbreak in 2017
and if you look at the the map of
illness on sets from last year it is
very similar to this recent outbreak
because these two are related
we have really more clues to go by now
in terms of of where people got sick and
the timing involved the CDC says about
48 million people get sick from
foodborne illnesses every year 46
percent of them from eating leafy
vegetable
and other produce cooking kills most
germs found in food but because romaine
lettuce is usually eaten raw that's not
really an option the CDC says just throw
it out it's not worth the risk for CBS
this morning and a Werner New York and
that's that's the key point it's not
worth just throw it out it's not a win
in doubt just get rid of it no matter
how long you've had it you got a toss
eat your greens just not yeah move over
to Kaelin spin it